For me they're meant to be
thrown around, worn everywhere.
It's something that you should be wearing.
You should live in it.
And it should tell that
story of your life.
It's like this personal
journal of experience.
I'm Savannah Yarborough and we are
at the Atelier Savas studio.
One of the first pieces that I designed
when I was working for a bigger company
was a leather jacket.
It was really like flat and
wasn't interesting at all.
I took the sample home.
I put it in my bathtub and
I wore it while it dried.
It molded to me.
It was different from
putting on anything else
that I'd ever had.
I met people in the factories
that were actually making
these jackets and I learned
a lot from those people.
So whether it's a $200 leather jacket
or a $10,000 leather jacket,
it's gonna last forever.
It's gonna change every time they wear it.
It it rains, you're gonna be okay
and your leather jacket's gonna look
five times better when it dries.
The first phase of making
one of our leather jackets is
meeting with the client, select
the leather that they want,
any embroidery or specific
details that they might also
wanna add, and we actually
draw out the jacket for them.
After that, we take 32
points of measurement.
With the word bespoke, the person who's
taking your measurements
is also the person
that's with your piece
the whole way through.
I'm making the jacket
that you will be wearing.
Physically, myself, I can only
make four jackets a month.
The second phase, is to
create the paper pattern
based on the measurements.
These two dimensional pieces that will
then be put together to
create the actual 3D jacket.
The armhole and the shoulder,
that's the most complicated
place to fit and I've developed
a really great pattern
to be able to adapt it for each person.
It's a really really beautiful armhole.
As a designer, that's the first thing you
look at when you look
at a jacket or a coat.
Like how beautiful does that sleeve hang.
We make a fabric version
which is basically a mock up
of what their leather jacket will be.
There's always some
sort of tweaks that have
to be done before we actually cut.
Once the needle goes through the leather,
you can't take back that hole.
There's always gonna be a
hole where the needle was.
When I sell a leather,
when they pick their skin,
that leather is no
longer gonna be available
to any other client.
Oh, I saw my friend Joe and
he was in this really cool
red leather jacket, I want that jacket.
I want that leather.
I won't sell it to you.
We will find you another red leather
and you will have your
own one-of-a-kind piece.
The jacket that I'm wearing is this really
buttery soft calfskin.
There's silk lining in it.
A western yoke detail here.
Silver zippers.
When people feel it, they're like,
"Oh my gosh, what is that?"
The third step involves cutting.
We lay out all of the skins.
We examine each skin
for any nicks or holes,
any scratches that we may
not want on the jacket.
Some leathers are more distressed already
and they show natural
grain from the animal
and so you want that in the jacket.
How are all 50 of these
pattern pieces gonna actually
fit into these hides that
are all different sizes.
Each one was a different animal.
The embroidery, it's a lot
of fun and it's something
that we offer most
specifically on the linings
of everyone's jackets and
give people an opportunity
to have this like very
personal interior detail
and it can be anything; their
nickname or an illustration.
It's this private detail
that no one knows about
because it's on the
inside of their jacket.
The fourth step in the
process of making a jacket,
you have to do things like
stabilize certain areas
like the waistbands, the
cuffs, and the collars,
scything the leather if it's too thick;
basically cuts the thickness
of the leather in half.
It gets rid of the bulk so
that when you have seams
to fold over, it doesn't
add really any extra
to that which allows the
seams to actually lay flatter.
It's really just a matter
of like getting all
of the pieces ready to be sewn.
The fifth phase is where
we actually sit down
and sew the pieces together.
It's not necessarily,
okay we're gonna sit down
at the sewing machine and
it's all gonna be done.
You sew one seam and then
you have to iron it flat
and roll it out and glue the seam so
that everything stays
really flush and flat.
We just moved into our
studio downtown Nashville.
It's in a neighborhood called Pie Town
which is in a very up and coming area.
I've been here for three and a half years.
I've lived in London for five years
which is where I studied.
I've lived in San Francisco.
I grew up in Alabama.
There's a spirit about Nashville
that it's just really great.
Within the few years that I was here,
I felt this growth happen
and it's still happening.
There's no second thought in my head
of anything else I would rather be doing.
There is a leather jacket for everyone.
That's why I'm here; is to
basically help create these
pieces that even if it's
someone who has never
been able to envision
themselves in a leather jacket,
like we can make that jacket.
The most important part of identifying one
of my jackets is the visible logo
which is stamped in 22
carat gold on each jacket.
The second is the fit, especially
when viewed from the side.
I create this very specific
curve on every jacket that I do.
Slightly higher in the back
and it drops really
beautifully down to the front.
And then, we deliver the jacket.
Leather jackets always
look their best 10 years
after you've had them.
The most beautiful thing
to me on a leather jacket
when I see someone wearing
one, is the creases in the arm
because the elbow like stretches
out, but you can really
just see like now that, you
know, I've been wearing this
one, it's always got this really
beautiful crease going on.
Every experience that
you have in that jacket,
something evolves in that material.
It's like modern day armor
'cause it gives you this
like confidence that you really don't get
from any other piece of clothing.
You put on your leather
jacket and you feel
like you can walk out the
door and take on the world.